we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p an important
voicemail question about Bernie and his
Judaism let's take a listen
hello David Pakman this is Alan calling
from the t14 area code and my question
for you is that if Bernie Sanders does
indeed get elected for president right
and given the fact that he would be the
first Jewish president yes how likely is
that that he would be an immediate
target for assassination
oof goodbye yeah so listen there there
has not been that much overt
anti-semitism against Bernie so far in
the Democratic primary but rest assured
we're not gonna have to wait too long
for the anti-semitism to become very
bold and blatant if indeed Bernie
Sanders is the nominee now as far as
assassination stuff every president
deals with assassination threats Barack
Obama saw a huge increase relative to
prior presidents Barack Obama of course
the first black president there is no
doubt that Secret Service is going to
have its hands full with Bernie even as
the mere nominee never mind as president
of the United States that don't worry if
you're waiting for the anti-semitism you
are going to see it it always is there
when there is an opportunity and Bernie
Sanders as a nominee or president would
be a major major opportunity I promise
you that we are going to see it we've
got a great bonus show for you today we
will talk about the great airplane seat
reclining debate we will talk about Jeff
Bezos is ten billion dollar pledge to
fight climate change and much much more
don't miss today's bonus show get
instant access to it by becoming a
member or a patron I'll see you then